We have a voicemail number. That number is two
one nine two David P.. Here's a great question
about what would Trump be doing now if the
situation were reversed? Take a listen to this.
What would they do if the circumstances were
reversed and Biden were sick? They would move
in for the kill? I think right. I think that
there is a parallel between the number of people
that Trump has allowed to get sick
and the fact that he allowed himself
and his people in his entourage to get sick. It
just goes to show he's unfit. And they would show
no mercy if the situation were reversed.
So maybe you want to do a show about that.
There is absolutely no question about it.
You know, Joe Biden, when Donald Trump was
was positive for Corona virus, immediately
announced he was pulling negative ads,
that he was sending his best wishes. Barack
Obama sent best wishes. You even had anchors
like on MSNBC talking about Trump's new
tone and all of this stuff. And meanwhile,
as Donald Trump is being airlifted to Walter
Reed Hospital amid a cloud of dishonesty and and
confusion about his actual condition, the Trump
campaign is sending out fundraising e-mails about
Lions', sleepy Joe and all of this insane,
conspiratorial nonsense that they email people
about all the time. Trump is back on Twitter
already. It is abundantly clear that Joe Biden
has done everything right. Joe Biden's campaign
events abide by the CDC guidelines. Joe Biden,
despite having been onstage with what was likely
a contagious Trump during that first debate,
has fortunately, as of this moment of recording,
tested negative for Corona virus three times.
Joe Biden just needs to keep running a campaign
period. And, you know, negative that he's
going to run positive ads, but not negative
ads. Criticizing Trump on policy is fair game.
We have an election. Someone is going to be
president the next four years. And I think that it
is if if it was reversed, just imagine they would
be running ads saying weak. Biden got the virus
masks don't work because Biden wore a big
mask and got the virus anyway. Imagine if
he got it from Trump while being onstage during
a moment where supposedly everybody onstage had
been tested and tested negative. They would
be running negative ads. They wouldn't stop
anything. There is no question about it.
I don't think there's anything wrong with
Joe Biden simply continuing to campaign.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
What's going to happen with the confirmation of
Amy CONI Barrett as a result of Trump testing
positive? Because it's not just Trump, Mike Lee
and two other Republican senators, Ron Johnson
and one more I forget the name have tested
positive if they can't be there. Plus,
Murkowski and Collins won't vote before
the election. They don't have the votes.
So we're going to talk about that. And more and
more things are pointing to the lame duck period.
Regal Cinemas is closing all cinemas in the
United States and the United Kingdom on Thursday.
Are we seeing the beginning of the end of
the movie theater industry? And lastly,
eleven positive corona virus tests have now been
traced specifically to the presidential debate.
According to Cleveland officials, we are
going to talk about whether they will have
any ability to enforce the rules if debates
number two and three happen. And of course,
at the vice presidential debate, which still as
of right now and things, ST's changed so quickly,
which is why I say it that way. As of right now,
it's still scheduled for this Wednesday night at
9:00 p.m. Eastern Time. If, indeed, the debate
happens Wednesday night, the V.P. debate, I will
be streaming live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
I hope you will join me for what I think will be
an absolute brutalizing of
Mike Pence by Kamala Harris.